>> Laura: A FEW MORE LIBERAL
REPUBLICANS ARE PUSHING A BILL
IN THE HOUSE TO LEGALIZE B12 AND
PROTECT THE SO-CALLED DREAMERS
FROM DEPORTATION.
HOUSE SPEAKER PAUL RYAN DISMISS
THE MEASURE AS A SHOW PONY AND
SAID HE WANTS TO BUILD A
PRESIDENT CAN SIGN.
THE BILL IS ALSO AT ODDS WITH
HOW CONSERVATIVES WHO FAVOR
CONGRESSMAN BOB GOODLATTE TOUGH,
SMART, PRAGMATIC IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT MEASURE.
LET'S DISCUSS WHERE THIS IS ALL
HEADING.
IT'S A THREE CARD MONTE GOING ON
ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
DAVE BRAT, THIS IS WILD BECAUSE
IF PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS MODERATE LIBERAL REPUBLICAN
PUSH FOR A DACA BILL AND SAYING
THAT IS THE PATHWAY TO THE
GOODLATTE BILL, WHAT?
IT'S NOT A PATHWAY TO THE GOOD
LOVE BILL.
IT'S A NIGHTMARE.
>> THERE IS A COMPLICATED
TECHNICAL THING.
FOUR BILLS AND PLAY.
GOODLATTE WON'T PASS.
WHAT DOES PASS QUESTIONING THE
DREAMER BILL.
3.6 MILLION DREAMERS WITH JANE
IN TEN YEARS IT'S 10 MILLION
ILLEGAL GRANTED PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP.
SPEAKER RYAN SAID WE ARE GOING
TO PASS THE GOODLATTE BILL.
IT IT IS IN COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS TOLD ME IT HASN'T PASSED
OUT OF COMMITTEE.
THAT'S THE FIRST STEP.
IF THEY WANT TO WHIP IT, THEY
CAN GET THE GOODLATTE BILL.
>> Laura: EVERYONE WATCHING
NEEDS TO KNOW PAUL RYAN, WE LIKE
PAUL RYAN BUDDIES ON HIS WAY OUT
HAS NOT MOVED THIS BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITTEE HAS TO MOVE IT OUT
TO CONSIDER ABOUT ON THE FLOOR.
IT HAS TO GO TO THE SENATE.
THE SENATE IS NOT GOING TO PROVE
THE GOODLAD BILL.
60 VOTES IN THE SENATE IS A
PROBLEM.
>> YOU CAN USE IT FOR THE
MIDTERMS.
CAN I PLAY SOMETHING FOR YOU.
THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT WAS IN
INDIANA.
THIS MADE ME SMILE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> JOE DONNELLY VOTED AGAINST
ENHANCED VETTING.
THINK OF THAT.
WHAT, WHAT IN THE WORLD WOULD
ANYBODY BE DOING VOTING AGAINST
ENHANCED VETTING?
WHY?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> Laura: ENHANCED VETTING FOR
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE COUNTRY.
WHO THEY ARE, WHY THEY'RE HERE,
REFUGEES OR ANYONE ELSE.
>> THE GOODLAD BILL DOES
EVERYTHING WE WANT.
E-VERIFY, CHAIN MIGRATION,
BUILDS THE WALL.
EVERYTHING.
SENATOR OBAMA WAS FOR ALL OF
THAT.
>> Laura: HE WAS MR. BORDER
HAWK.
>> THE GOODLATTE BILL IS A
COPPER VISE.
THE DEMOCRATS ASKED THOUSAND
DACA, GET THEM OUT OF THE
SHADOWS MIGHT GIVE THEM PATHWAY
TO STATUS.
WE SAID OKAY, WILL COMPROMISE
WITH YOU.
TRUMP OFFERS 2 MILLION.
A BIGGER COMPROMISE.
DEMOCRATS SAY NO.
NOW WE HAVE 25 REPUBLICANS DOING
AN END RUN WITH 200 DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S THE PLAY.
THE PEOPLE AT HOME MISSED THE
MAIN POINT, IT'S 25 REPUBLICANS
LEAPFROGGING OVER LEADERSHIP.
IF THEY GET 25 --
>> Laura: ALL THEY NEED IS 25.
AND THEN DACA IS THE LAW OF THE
LANDS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
EVERYBODY WATCHING UNDERSTANDS
WE NEED THE GOODLATTE BILL.
IT'S A TRICK PONY.
IT'S NOT A SHOW PONY.
>> IT'S A TROJAN HORSE.
>> Laura: WE ARE ON EVERY
EQUINE REFERENCE HERE.